during her life and even in her death
Amplified Palestinian voices now
Palestinians want to make sure her voice
doesn't fade away
[Music]
representatives from Al Jazeera media
Network and the Ramallah municipality
laid the Cornerstone of the Shireen
Museum
an interactive project that is expected
to open in 2025 honoring a veteran
journalist who didn't want to leave a
story Untold and I will tell her your
sharing about ugly the most important
journalist in Palestine
is a long time friend of Shireen she
says the initiative shows loyalty to a
trailblazing reporter I kept asking her
do you have an archive do you keep an
archive and then she said no no no but
al-shazira does
I feel now when you know I wish that
she's alive just to see how much love
her people keep how much love
Ramallah to donate this piece of land a
song to remember one of their own
was performed by the daughters of
Jerusalem band in another event marking
a year after her killing
she didn't only tell stories of the
Israeli occupation those who knew
Shareen say she loved to report on
happier stories one's own culture
Innovation and Hope
[Music]
streets have been named after her an
awards given in her name but many
Palestinians say the biggest honor of
all is that she remains in people's
hearts on Thursday beerset University
granted four Palestinian journalists the
Shireen award for media excellence
keeps reminding us of the brutality of
the Israeli occupation that Justice for
her is yet to be served and that we
should carry on the message
been a year since Palestine lost one of
its best storytellers one year with no
sign of justice for Shireen as her
killers are yet to be held accountable
I can see journals that they will think
twice and three times before going to
the field they will think that they want
to go with an armored car with a vest
with the helmet and they're not sure
what will happen they're not sure that
they can make it to the location that
they can go and that they will be safe
sharia's life might have ended here in
Janine but her Legacy lives on in the
stories she covered and the ones her
colleagues promised to keep telling me
Ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied West
Bank
well the U.S has pledged